The 1990s gave us a word for the slow unraveling of meaning, non-places.
Marc Auger called them that, spaces so hollow they don't even pretend to be somewhere.
Airports where the only history is the last flight delay.
Hotel lobbies where the only art is the flickering of fluorescent lights.
Supermarkets where the produce looks like it was grown in a lab, not a field.
And here's the thing, we didn't just tolerate them, we made them our homes.
The architecture of blandness isn't just about passing through, it's about living in the void.
It's the suburban office park where the drywall partitions are so neutral they might as well be made of silence.
It's the commute that's a series of motorways and parking lots,
a carefully curated absence of anything that might remind you you're alive.
It's the hotel room where the view is another parking lot,
because even the illusion of a horizon is too much to ask.
You want to be disconnected? Then design your world to be as featureless as a loading screen.
Start with the commute. No local parks, no historic streets,
just the smooth, frictionless slide of asphalt and glass.
The kind of place where you could swap faces with anyone and no one would notice.
You're not a person here. You're a ghost of the interface,
flickering between screens and spaces that were never meant to hold you.
Then comes the workspace. A desk so sterile it could belong to anyone or no one.
No photos, no plants, not even a coffee stain to suggest someone actually lives here.
The only sound is the digital hum, that white noise of a thousand unread emails and half-finished tasks.
This isn't a place to create. It's a place to disappear.
And if you move, choose the same gray flooring, the same white counters, the same neutral lighting.
The global aesthetic doesn't just travel with you, it erases you.
No hedonic adaptation needed. You've already adapted. You become the void.
Even travel becomes an exercise in erasure.
Stay in the same chain hotels where the view is always a parking lot or a skyline,
so generic it might as well be a screenshot.
No sunsets, no street lamps, no natural light to remind you the world outside still exists.
Sunlight is a placemaker.
It changes with the seasons, with the time of day.
But in the sensory desert, the light is artificial, unchanging, just like everything else.
The goal? To become the sovereign of the void.
A person who is at home everywhere because they are truly at home nowhere.
Where every space you inhabit is as forgettable as the person inhabiting it.
A beautiful building is a challenge to the soul.
A generic building is a promise of peace.
Choose the peace of the void.